well hey everyone um this is definitely
a video that i really
never wanted to make and let me explain
why a couple of months ago i put out a
video about seventh day adventists
and in that video i compared and
contrasted
some of the differences and common
beliefs between
adventists and uh non-adventists we'll
refer to them as evangelical christians
now that video was not necessarily
incorrect
but unfortunately it was incomplete
and i confess to you that i did not go
far enough in my
own personal research to truly dig
beneath the surface and truly understand
what the seventh-day adventist faith
actually does believe
and what will happen is this is whenever
you talk to somebody
from the adventist faith they are
trained
to basically only tell you some of the
things that they believe
or just basically stay on the surface in
fear
that if they really tell you some of the
big differences between what they really
believe and what they've been trained
and raised to believe
and what you as an evangelical christian
believe
that they are going to lose or miss out
on the opportunity
to convert you over to being an
adventist
which is basically what their overall
position or their
overall attempt is is to really try to
convert you
because as i'm going to share in this
video along with a couple other videos
that i'm going to do in this little
short series they truly believe that if
you
do not keep the sabbath you are an
apostate you are
a rebellion a rebellious person rather
and god's favor is not on your life
so these are some of the things that as
i dug
deep into what they believe that i found
that there were some major
major problems with the adventist faith
and i want to go through those
slowly in a couple of videos now just a
disclaimer these are not going to be
short videos so if you're looking for
short videos
these are not the ones because i have to
really
not do what i did last time i have to
really go deep and explain these things
so once again
my commitment to you all on this channel
is to always
preach the truth of the word of god but
when
i get it wrong you have my word that i
will always be humble enough to come
back
and admit to you that something that i
said in the past
was not correct and as a result after
releasing this video i'm going to pull
that previous video down because i don't
want the ad money anymore i don't want
any of the reviews i don't want my
numbers to go up i don't want that video
to lead
any more people astray by causing them
to think
that it's okay to be a part of this
seventh-day adventist
movement so i'm going to talk about
several things in
this video but let me first make it
clear
what i'm talking to you in this video
about are
beliefs of the adventist movement as
a whole and for that reason that's why
i'm going to take you over to their
website
where their beliefs are and i'm going to
show you what the movement
actually believes i'm not attacking any
one specific member
because i don't know what every single
member of the adventist church believes
individually but i'm just simply going
to show you some of the errors
or the false beliefs if you will of the
adventist
church as a whole and then i want you to
really make up your decision as to
whether you think
that it is actually the same now if
hopefully if you allow me here i'm
probably going to make some mistakes
this is just
me being off the cuff here i'm going to
use my notes because there's a lot of
things that i
wrote down that i really want to make
sure i remember and give to you
so hopefully you'll allow me looking
over here on my notes
as i get into this now the first thing
that i really want to talk about i want
to share a scripture which is the
foundation
for everything that i'm going to talk
about in these next couple videos
is found in galatians chapter 1
verses 6 through 9. all right galatians
chapter 1 verses 6 through 9.
and basically paul says this i marvel
that you are turning away
so soon from him who called you in the
grace of christ
to a different gospel which is not
another
but there are some who trouble you and
want to pervert the gospel of christ
but even if we or an angel from heaven
preach any other gospel to you than what
we have
preached to you let him be accursed
and then paul says it again as we have
said before so i say again
if anyone preaches another gospel
if anyone preaches another gospel any
other gospel to you than what you have
received
let him be accursed paul says i am so
confident in the gospel i've already
communicated to you that it is truly
from the word of god and from the from
the
mind of god that even if i come back and
say an angel showed me something else
that was different than what i shared
with you then let me be accursed right
now what if
excuse me what is the gospel of jesus
christ
it says here in ephesians 1 8 9 for by
grace you have been saved through faith
and that not of yourselves it is the
gift of god
not of works lest anyone should boast
now why do i share that scripture
because whenever you dig deep into the
seventh-day adventist
faith what you will see as you
uncover layer after layer after layer
you finally get down
to it you'll see that they truly do
teach
a works based salvation
there's no certainty of salvation in
their faith
there's they don't even believe that you
can you are saved right now
they believe that you're being saved or
you will be saved
something of that nature which we'll
talk about in just a moment
but this gospel that paul presented
here is that we are saved by grace
through faith and this is not a result
of ourselves
this is not something we can boast about
it's not by works
paul says if anyone comes to you and
says anything different about
this gospel and the salvation and how
you get saved
it's a false gospel it's not a gospel
and that person needs to be accursed
now with all that being said i don't
know how much we're going to get through
in this particular video
but what i want to talk about first is
the foundation of the adventist church
right so i want you to think of the
adventist church
as a house now at the bottom of that
house
and every house there's a foundation
the foundation of the adventist church
whether you talk to somebody and they
agree or not
just trust me on this one is the
teachings
of their prophet ellen g white
ellen g white if you talk to about uh if
there's a survey out
that where 86 of the members
of the adventist church say that they
believe
support and wholeheartedly believe that
the teachings of
ellen g white are a source of authority
for
their particular church so my goal in
this video
and we'll see how far we get is if i can
cut down or undermine the foundation of
the adventist church
i.e the teachings and the prophecies of
ellen g
white then my friend you can basically
tear down the entire
adventist faith because they
really hold allen g white and her
teachings and her prophecies
as being uh almost authoritative
all right and i'm going to show you that
in just a moment so let me begin
first and foremost the main one of the
biggest problems here
is that ellen g white is a
woman all right now there's nothing
wrong with that but
the bible clearly teaches that in terms
of
spiritual authority in the church and
uh teaching doctrine and exercising
authority
over men in the church that this is
prohibited
right now we're not going to argue about
that right here the scripture
says in first timothy 2 12 i do not
permit a woman to teach or to assume
authority over a man now once again
um we're not going to get into that
first timothy 2 12 i believe it is
um but essentially that right there is
one of the biggest problems in the
adventist
is that is that their entire theology
for the most part was formed and
formulated by
ellen g white one of their uh early
prophetesses now
uh let me just go down the list of a few
things
that are problematic with some of the
beliefs some of her teachings if you
will first and foremost
we will look at um
the authority of the bible so now what
i'm going to do is i'm going to take you
over to
the adventist.org website all right
i'm going to take you over to the
adventist.org website where it says
seventh-day adventists
accept the bible as the only source of
our beliefs
we consider our movement to be the
result
of the protestant conviction sola
scriptura now if you don't know what
solo script remains
solo only scriptura scripture so that
basically they're saying
only scripture we believe in only
scripture okay the bible has the only
standard of faith and practice for
christians now you may think brother
allen that sounds about the same thing
that we say as evangelical christians
you're right
that's exactly what they want you to
think right yeah we believe in the bible
and only the bible
but let's go deeper okay let's go deeper
so
now let's talk about um
ellen g white all right and her how they
view her position in terms of her
authority to interpret this one
soul truth now i'm going to go over here
to this website
and let me um blow this up here
notice what it says it says here
and this is one of their one of what
this is their position on ellen g white
one of the gifts of the holy spirit is
prophecy okay that's true
this gift is an is an identifying mark
of the remnant church
and was manifested in the ministry of
ellen g
white okay fine as the lord's messenger
here's the problem her writings
are a continuing and authoritative
source of truth which
provide for the church comfort guidance
instruction and correction they also
make clear that the bible is the
standard by which all
teaching and experience must be tested
now i want you to go back to this phrase
right here her writings are a continuing
and authoritative source of truth
my friend that is a problem her writings
are a continuing
and authoritative source of truth
my friend that is basically
elevating her writings on par
with the level of the apostle paul
there are members of the adventist
church that believe that ellen g
white's writings were inspired by
god and on the same level as the apostle
paul
they believe that her commentary on the
bible
right is is divinely inspired if you
will
so this is a major major problem but i'm
getting ahead of myself okay so just
slow down
now watch this i want you to notice here
that this
was the previous statement that was on
the adventist.org website
her writings are continuing and
authoritative source of truth
now i want to show you what it says as
of today
as of today whenever you click on the
adventist.org
website it says here
this gift is an identify mark of the
remnant church
and we believe it was manifested in the
ministry of ellen d white
her writings speak with prophetic
authority
and provide comfort and guidance blah
blah blah blah do you see what they did
do you see what they did they removed
the phrase that her writings were um
uh what did they say a authority a
continuing
uh a continuing and authoritative source
of truth
they removed that phrase from their
website
why because they had such a difficult
time
trying to harmonize some of her false
teachings and false beliefs
with the scriptures right and they
also hopefully i'm assuming came to the
place where they realize
that you can't call any human being
other than the people who wrote the
scriptures
and say that their writings were an
authoritative source
of truth no no there is no more
authoritative source of truth other than
these
the new testament scriptures okay so now
that's just that's not it okay um
they i want to basically highlight the
big difference here
as evangelical christians
we read the scriptures and then
we look at other commentaries
and if those commentaries don't line up
with scripture we throw those
commentaries
out because those commentaries
are supposed to help us understand the
scriptures
but if in any situation where it's
different
we don't rely on the commentaries
interpreting what the bible says we say
no this is what the bible says and
therefore those commentaries must be
wrong
my understanding of the adventist church
is it's almost flipped you have the
bible
but the bible is only the the only
source of truth
as it is first understood
and interpreted by ellen g white
do you see the difference right in other
words
yes we believe in the bible we believe
in only the bible
as it is interpreted and understood by
lng white
if ellen g white says this is what the
bible teaches about the sabbath about
salvation
about investigative judgment which we're
going to talk about later please
don't don't stop this video don't stop
this video because i'm going to get into
this other issue that is the biggest
heresy in their movement
in just a couple of minutes right but
they depend significantly on
her understanding and interpretation of
the bible
and whatever that is that is what
causes them to believe their beliefs
okay so that's a huge difference
now let me show you what ellen g white
says about her own authority
okay now first i want to read to you
what the bible says
and that's what i'm gonna do the rest of
this video i'm going to show you kind of
what the bible says about something
and then i'm going to show you the
adventist position and how it's
it's not correct in several regards the
bible says this in hebrews 1 1
god who at various times and in various
ways
spoke in times past to the fathers
by the prophets has in these last days
here it is
listen spoken to us by his son whom he
has
appointed heir of all things so what is
the author of hebrews saying he's saying
in the past
god spoke to us through the prophets but
today god speaks to us
through his son meaning
jesus along with the apostles who had
the heart of christ and
understood his doctrine that is how we
hear from god jesus is who speaks to us
today
through the written word of god
now i want you to see what ellen g white
has said about herself
and how similar it is to hebrews
1 1. ok notice she says this
she says let me get to this
all right uh she says
in ancient times god spoke to men by the
mouth of prophets and apostles
sounds very similar in these days he
speaks to them by the testimonies
of his spirit now just so you know so
you're clear
any time you see the phrase testimonies
of his spirit
think of ellen g white think of lng
white any time that an adventist refers
to that phrase the testimonies
the prophecies the testimonies of his
spirit
they're primarily referring to ellen g
white and her
teachings so what is she saying do you
see what she did
she is inserting her name using
scriptural language to say in the past
god spoke to people by
prophets and apostles but today
he speaks to people through me
through the testimonies of the spirit by
what god is showing me
by the way many of her revelations
visions or prophecies
she believed that she received them from
an angel
right from an angel now what's
interesting is that paul said in
galatians chapter one
even if an angel comes and says that
there's a different gospel let
let that man be accursed right so many
of her teachings
she claims that she got this from an
angel all right so notice i just want
you to be clear see what she's saying
hebrews 1 says in these last days god
spoken to us by jesus
she puts herself in here and says in the
last days god speaks to us
in the testimonies of his spirit by his
spirit or whatever is he saying
testimonies of his spirit
in other words he's speaking through me
and other prophets like me
my friend that's not true that's that is
a violation of scripture
and that is not what the bible says
so let's keep going here all right even
one of their revered
members robert olson said
this he said i believe that both ellen g
white and the apostle paul were true
prophets who wrote under the influence
of the holy spirit
my reason for believing in the
inspiration of one
is identical to my reason for believing
in the
other my friend that is very problematic
when you have members in your church
that say
that even mention of ellen g white and
apostle paul
in the same sentence right that is a
major major problem
and say that my reason for believing in
ellen g white's
truth is identical to believing in the
apostle paul
my friend that that is heresy and
there's a problem there all right so
let's move on now excuse me to the
biggest
heresy that way if you don't watch any
of the other videos you'll get this one
i'm going to go after the biggest heresy
in the adventist
church and it is something called the
investigative
judgment now i can't go into every
single detail but i'll do my best
the investigative judgment is
the biggest heresy of the adventist
church and i'm gonna expose it now okay
if you're not familiar with it you can
google it you can check it out
but let me just give you a little
background so you understand
where this came from okay the adventists
were founded by a guy by the name of
william
miller and they were originally called
millerites
william miller was he considered himself
a a prophet or excuse me
one that um was familiar with
or uh really interested in
bible prophecy if you will so excuse my
excuse me for
mumbling but basically he had a prophecy
that christ was going to return let me
see if i can get this right
in bodily form on april 23 1843
now obviously christ did not return in
bodily form in
april on april 23 1843 so
he went back and recalculated some
things and he realized okay well maybe i
got the date wrong
so then he said christ is going to
return in on march 21st really he said
in the springtime of 1844 and so then
they came up with the date march 21st
jesus didn't return on march 21st 1844.
then he said okay well you know what i
got off i got off okay
i'm gonna recalculate it again it's
going to be in the fall of this year
sometime
so they came up now with the date of
october 22nd
1844 well clearly christ did not come
back
on apr on october 22nd 1844
and so as a result william miller was
devastated
because he of these false prophecies and
by the way
the bible says the no man knows the day
nor the hour of the lord's return and
that we shouldn't even try to figure it
out
that's another problem right you have
the founder of this entire movement
and it was based on a man trying to
figure out the
the lord's return when the bible clearly
says we shouldn't even be trying to do
that right
but let me get back so now
what happened was a couple of members
from the adventist church
instead of just confessing and saying
you know what
we were wrong we got the dates wrong
we shouldn't have even tried to even do
that we don't know when christ is coming
right instead of just simply repenting
what they did was because a lot of
people were leaving the movement because
they were
losing trust and faith in william miller
and his followers
and so the movement was slowly dying off
but then what happened was a couple of
people one guy by the name of crozier
and a couple of other people they came
up with this idea of what's called the
investigative
judgment which i'm going to talk about
in just a minute just hold on for a
second
all right and the investigative judgment
so basically what they said was this
they said well we didn't really get the
date wrong
the date really truly is still october
22nd
1844 but we got the event wrong
jesus christ is not really going to
return to the earth
in bodily form no instead
he's going to enter into the heavenly
sanctuary
where he is going to start a
work called the investigative judgment
and this is where it originated right
instead of just confessing we were off
we shouldn't have did it we made a
mistake we repent
we're sorry no they had to hold on to
the william miller's prophecy
and say that okay yeah we got the date
right
we just got the event wrong the event is
that instead of jesus coming to the
earth in bodily form
instead he's going to go into the
heavenly sanctuary into the most holy
place
where he's going to begin an
investigative judgment now what is this
investigative judgment
it is the idea that jesus christ
is in the heavenly sanctuary in the most
holy place
and he is investigating the lives of
every single believer
and he's going through all of your sins
and he's going through all of the things
that you've done wrong
and he's investigating it he's
investigating it
to one day make a judgment about whether
you
are going to be in heaven or hell that's
why it's called the investigative
judgment he is currently in heaven at
this time
looking at everything that you're doing
are you obeying the sabbath are you
looking at pornography
are you lusting are you lying are you
stealing are you for are you forgiving
people
are you coveting people are you jealous
he's investigating every detail of your
life
and then he's going to make a judgment
and he's going to
judge whether you are fit to be in
heaven or hell my friend
that is a perversion of the gospel
that is a perversion of the work
of christ on the cross that is an insult
to the atonement
of jesus christ because clearly the
bible teaches
that our sins past present and future
are already paid for
the bible teaches that when jesus got on
the cross
he said it is finished all right let me
i'm getting ahead of myself here
let me just read some scripture for you
all right let me read some scripture
the bible says this in hebrews 10 but
this man jesus after he had offered
one sacrifice for sins forever
sat down on the right hand of god
from henceforth expecting till his
enemies be made his footstool
by one for by one offering he had
perfected
forever them that are sanctified
whenever you're finished with something
what do you do you sit down
right the bible says that christ sat
down at the right hand of the father and
he's
making intercession for you and i it
doesn't teach that
jesus is up in heaven somewhere writing
down
and identifying everything that you and
i do right or wrong
making a judgment and investigating the
details of our lives
that is not the bible that's not the the
atonement right
that's not what the bible says notice
the bible also says this there is
therefore now
no condemnation to those who are in
christ
jesus who walk not after the flesh but
after
the spirit answer me this question how
can god
be investigating every detail of your
life
and there also at the same time be no
condemnation on your life for those who
are in christ jesus
how can the bible say that there's no
condemnation on your life
but yet there very well might be because
right now god's investigating everything
that you're doing
you see this is the problem with the
advent this is the biggest
foundational problem is that there's no
certainty in salvation with them
that's why they have to obey the sabbath
that's why they have to eat certain
things that's why they have to
do all this stuff because they believe
that christ is in heaven and he's
currently investigating all of their
lives
and their salvation is not really secure
and so as a result
you know what i can't really be certain
about my salvation
so therefore i've got to do all these
things it's a works based
faith it's a workspace salvation which
is why
you need to steer clear of this all
right
so uh let's keep going john 19 30 jesus
said on the cross
it is finished right vacant
they suggest that it's still going on in
heaven that he's still making this
investigative judgment the bible says
that our sins are forgiven
and forgotten hebrews chapter 8 verse
12.
ellen g white in the great controversy
says this through the grace of god
and their own diligent effort
they must be conquerors in the battle
with evil
do you see that through the grace of god
and their own diligent effort
they must be conquerors in the battle
with evil
do you see what she did she combined
the grace of god and your own diligent
effort
and if you have both of those then you
can be conquerors then you can get into
heaven then you can be saved
my friends that is not what the bible
teaches
that now reduces christianity to every
other world religion
the difference between christianity and
any other world religion
is that we believe that salvation is by
grace through faith alone
no works every other religion believes
that you have to work or do
something in order to get to heaven and
this my friend
is what the adventist church is teaching
under the surface when you peel back all
of these different
layers all right now um let me see if
there's anything else
that i forgot to uh
address here all right
um let's see
all right so my friend that i think is
going to be
enough for this first video now in the
next video
i'm going to go deep into another
very very huge heresy that the adventist
church
promotes and that is this idea of the
sabbath
we're gonna break that down we're gonna
break that down detail by detail because
they truly believe that the sabbath
is one of the ways that you can secure
your salvation is by obeying the sabbath
hence the name seventh-day adventist and
we're gonna we're gonna debunk that
we're gonna expose that
we are going to break that down in the
next video
so um hopefully that was clear so to be
very clear before i leave you
the two primary things that we talked
about in this video number one
is their elevation of ellen g white
and her teachings and her prophecies and
her testimonies
as being on par or
on the same level or having
authoritative truth
as scripture now they won't say that
but when you dig and dig and dig most of
their understanding
and interpretation of scripture
comes as a result of ellen g white's
understanding and interpretation of
scripture
the second thing we talked about is this
idea of the investigative judgment
once again this is the idea that your
salvation is not secure
that jesus christ instead of sitting at
the right of the father making session
for you
instead he's up in heaven in the most
holy place making an investigative
judgment
on your life and all the lives of those
who have
uh all the all the believers and
the judgment is still going on to this
day and so therefore you better be very
careful how you live
because your name could be blotted out
of the book of life
okay once again that's a that is a
a insult to the atonement of christ
and it is not consistent with biblical
truth in terms of what salvation is all
about
so hopefully that was helpful um
i once again i apologize that i did not
go
far enough in my first video to make it
clear
as to what this group actually believes
when you
pull back the layers i'm going to
in the in the description i'm going to
put a couple of links
of some websites that you can go to to
find out even more
about uh what they believe now let me
just say this last thing and then i'm
leaving
if you're an adventist watching this
please know that i'm not against you i
love you
and then i love you with you know in the
love of the lord
and i hope and pray that the lord
will remove the scales from your eyes
and then you'll just read the scriptures
and you won't depend on ellen g white's
teachings
you'll let the scriptures inform what it
is you believe
and you will compare what is written in
the word
with some of the things that you're
being taught and i trust that if you go
after that truth
god will certainly reveal it to you god
bless my friends i'll see you in the
next video when we continue this
series bye for now